cheers cheers
cheers i got my little shot over here
yeah
there we go took a shot
all right we're going to talk about how
to sound smart today yeah everybody
where we got big brains okay
you're covering them up with your
sweater you know what uh the the tighter
the sweater the bigger and get wetter i
don't know yeah yeah
okay sense this is working out very well
because this episode is about grammar
mistakes oh did i done messed up the
whole sentence right there all right you
know what i just thought i was speaking
real nice i found this article on cnbc
because i'm a nerd and it's talking
about we asked dozens of managers what
bothered them the most when they talk to
employees and read emails or dms from
them most common managers complaint is
all the junk words and phrases
fillers useless clunky pretentious words
so i thought we should go through this
like people need to know like a lot of
this stuff like if you wanted to they
also need to gravity is your best friend
they also need to know who's here today
oh yeah who yeah
did you pick that because of me no
here we have a very special guest host
for the fourth week in a row this is
nicki blaze
if you're exotic if you're fancy
yeah
nikki who else is here
tiffany
casper
this is nikki i'll just simply go buy
blades
okay
yeah i'm trying to copy because then
nicki number two i follow
number ones are fancier than blades i
guess sometimes excuse me ma'am don't
start a fight
you pick her up i'm trying to make her
feel better by putting me down i'm not
trying to put you down just saying
you're tall today
so we decided to drink right before an
episode of a grammar expert episode here
because we thought that would make it a
little bit more fun
but it's still useful information we
could you know help enlighten people in
their shitty grammar can i just just
before we get started because i have a i
have beef right now i have a bone to
pick with this
with this with what this article uh or
would you even read it no no i didn't
okay
even more so but just how you defend it
already
okay so when i was growing up so i was
very early to read or i started reading
at three i started reading chapter books
at six i knew correct grammar from a
very young age it's good yeah but i got
picked on like bullied for it so because
i was a nerd so i had to learn how to
correct cool people
will because you only get bullied but i
couldn't be stable i couldn't stand it
because i got corrected by my parents so
then i couldn't stand it when people
would use improper grammar so then that
wasn't cool that wasn't cool it was a
very okay you're not cool so i had to i
had to retrain my brain to like speak
the vernacular that everyone else is
dumb it down is what you're saying
now if you talk like that then you're
not cool again if you don't use proper
grammar now you're not cool now now i'm
not cool again welcome to trends thanks
a lot
you cared about what little kids thought
i care a lot and that's the biggest
problem that's the biggest problem you
care too much
okay continue okay well we'll start with
the first one when someone says 3 a.m in
the morning um can you say what's wrong
redundancy yeah it's redundant okay
because 3 a.m it means the morning in
the morning so am actually stands for
ante meridium i think that's how you say
it everybody knows that
or meridian meridium meridium oh i think
that means like half before noon ante is
like before and then
i guess it's like middle which is that
is
i'm not sure if i'm even pronouncing
that right because that's not this
english
i don't know it's before noon it's like
atm machine
because automatic teller machine yeah
machine right teller machines i'm gonna
need alcohol for this episode cause off
tops i was like yes three a.m in the
morning what the [ __ ] is wrong with this
saturday yeah yeah
if you're singing eminem so it's three
am in the morning first off when it's
three am in the morning it normally it
looks like this is 3am in the morning so
basically just say 3 a.m and stop it
there or three in the morning or three
in the morning yeah
that works yeah that works so just be
aware when there's like abbreviations or
like words that actually mean what
you're already saying and then you
redundantly say the thing same thing
again like you said with atm machine
like asap as soon as possible like if
you well that's just repetitive yeah
sure
oh i'm about to fail this
i'm about episode fail again i was like
that sounds like it's 3am in the morning
turn up baby we going to do this what
are we doing this isn't pass fail this
is just fyi
oh cool i feel better about myself there
we go that people will judge you if you
do
you can't be right though okay ever
triggered
she said scooby doo doo doo
we pass it let's go
all right how about another one
absolutely essential
okay
okay if you say absolutely essential
yeah clearly the absolutely
yeah
when you're trying to pad it up right
yeah
stop doing that teachers ain't nobody
need to make that absolutely four
syllable words
okay
that's gonna be a rough episode i'll
read the i'll read the explanation on
this how about that okay let's go one
dictionary definition of essential is
absolutely necessary that's the
definition of essentials so it's like
the same thing with repetitiveness like
you're saying the same thing twice okay
like we don't need it to be
punched even harder because the word is
already a hard punch that sounds like
i've read that in a work email before um
yeah i'm saying like this is absolutely
necessary that you get this to me by
this afternoon okay absolutely necessary
yes but absolutely they're saying
absolutely necessary is also redundant
sure unnecessary but i feel like i've
heard people actually say yeah i've
heard yeah yeah okay so that's essential
or absolutely necessary it's exciting
too many words okay there's too many of
the same words basically same thing with
like actual fact because the definition
of
actual and factual
if you want to be cute
okay let's just look at the facts a fact
is something that's known to be true and
actual means existing in fact so i think
it's a lot of grammar mistakes sounds
like a dr seuss
book a lot of people saying the same
thing okay um i just downed a long
island i see yeah you're in for a ride
in this episode
your tongue's already she's not going to
be correcting all of our vernacular
correcting she said vernacular
no eminem lyrics please it's not eminem
it sounds like
it sounds like eminem because you've
been so obsessed with him oh i was kind
of in the the thing
yeah the like floorboards at the store
don't know harrison ford
these are way too many napkins
flapping the gapkin
okay
you know what is happening speaking of
vernacular you know who loves vernacular
it's eminem so you should listen up
because if you want him to respect you
when you meet him you need to speak
properly i'm not gonna be able to meet
him i'm not gonna be able to speak i'm
just gonna [ __ ] my pants
oh that's why your name is nikki number
two yay
that's what she's doing
yep
no
i could never i can't even look she
would vomit i honestly would black out
because of how nervous she is i think i
would black out
okay it's three a.m in the morning okay
moving on
another one depreciate in value
oh okay yeah yeah well i mean okay
you don't
i feel like these are used
to talk to people who don't necessarily
know the definition of the word to sound
like i'm being smart you're throwing
this big word in right you can pick up
on it because i've heard that yeah i
said before and i understood it until
you told me that's probably wrong and
then i'm like ah you're right it is it
just feels like an incomplete sentence
so if you're like your home will
depreciate
right it sounds like you should say to
me
it sounds like the end of this but
because you understand the proper
definition of the word i feel like it
definitely have heard depreciate and
value yeah
i think because i've heard it it feels
it feels like it should be afraid
because it's good
so much and because you understand the
proper
definition of the word you know that
that's how you end it i might probably
still say that though because like you
do pick up on the way people exactly so
and rhythmically it just makes it like
depreciate in value rather than this
home will depreciate
yeah
this home won't appreciate in value but
you can still get it
yeah i feel like they're connecting
words and you throw it in there like a
little
yeah again i
believe you know the definition but you
could speak to somebody who may not and
they could use it like they'll
understand the sentence and they'll be
like ah okay that means go down that's
another thing
that this one actually drives me crazy
is when people say you self-incriminated
yourself oh yeah
yeah yeah i can't get away i hear that i
know that's why i hear that so much and
i'm like oh or irregardless yeah i'm
sorry excuse me
we're irrigating words
irregardless it's just regardless okay
yeah
i'm gonna get all these irrigating
what farming ass episode is this
farming
okay what's next because what yeah what
that made me think of okay so like whole
not like we're talking how people talk
helps you fit into who you're talking to
which is to me better communication than
speaking proper grammar right you know
when who you can communicate what if
you're at work okay it depends
the the audience that you're talking you
play to that audience because there's
phrases like well that's a whole nother
thing whole nother is not yeah pull on
the other whole another that doesn't
make sense that's not an actual
grammatically correct thing to say but
people say it all the time people aren't
going to think you're less smart
it's another conversation that's wrong
yeah it's i could not well oh yeah i
couldn't care less do you think that
with without being a person that
corrects someone else like if you just
use proper english then you're in the
most part not like to be pretentious but
like if you say things the proper way
that you're at least kind of not
perpetuating saying things the wrong way
because like say take for example like
immigrants that are like first-gen
immigrants that come in and they're
they're speaking and they're trying to
learn english so if i talk back to the
lady that doesn't know how to use like
the at and and whatever you know like
the connecting words and she's just
using like can go grocery store if i
don't speak back to her in proper
english and help her like listen and
learn am i
i say depending read your room yes
social
etiquette and not etiquette what am i
saying like uh social currency like
understanding like the value in the room
like will it hurt the person
read the space like i got i have one of
my best friends who graduated from uc
davis in with a
degree in english who says pizza like
she's pizza she's from mexico and i say
pizza baby pizza she said pizza i said
pizza she said pizza i said pizza she
said pizza
you got the degree i don't so it's pizza
right but depending on who you're
talking to yeah i do feel like there's a
time and a place yeah for
proper
vernacular say you're a physicist you're
talking to a room full of physicists
you're going to talk in the scientific
terms of everything but if you're a
physicist talking to a bunch of general
public they're not going to understand
what the [ __ ] you're saying you have to
speak layman's terms even if it's even
if it's beneath your level right but if
you're just at work say because that's
what this article is
like i have to write a letter to my man
what's your i'm writing a memo like so
yeah
okay if you're in college if you're in
college if you're at work
whatever she was saying is what i was
going with but
in the way that you're saying it
absolutely
it is so vital when you have a chance if
you're in that space you're professional
yeah it also depends on how much of a
dick you want to be like if your body
has a [ __ ] and then you're like is it
absolutely necessary that i do this that
i would say that i would send that i
said you would never tell you is it
absolutely necessary i am my boss
i'm my boss
if you had a boss you could treat
yourself okay that's absolutely
necessary
there's nothing more entertaining than
speaking improper english concept to
someone who gives a [ __ ] no speaking
improper english constantly then
shocking the [ __ ] out of somebody when
you
actually
because if we're going in a work setting
i can see hearing [ __ ] all day i
love using improper words i mix
languages it's it's so much fun because
there's a lot of different cultures but
when that email comes in
and that proper english needs to be used
guess
guess who's in the house i love to bring
out the
to whom this made concerns nicole blaze
is in the house i call my mother for
backup at times i said excuse me mom uh
please help me write this email because
i like to piss them off and give them
the tone that i mean business she's like
i got you so
these phrases are vital if you're in a
work environment because some of these
when you use them improperly is a clear
sign that you don't know what you're
talking about but when you do the worse
but when you use them correctly it's one
of those
oh okay she's flexing okay all right we
should respect her uh-huh
and i was like nope but then i read her
email i was like oh oh okay
what else we got on this is i'm actually
pretty excited to hear what's next
here's
i felt bad no feel badly for some reason
many people think adding the l-y to bad
makes it sound better when spoken so
they say i feel badly but it's but you
should just say i feel bad
i feel bad i feel bad okay it doesn't
need to be badly right it's just i feel
like i feel bad is it i feel bad or i
felt i feel bad
okay yeah that badly sounds so weird to
me i don't think i've ever heard that
that feels the verb you don't need an
adverb after you just girl stops
speaking do you ever say i don't know
grammar [ __ ] do you ever say i feel
greatly no right so you wouldn't say i
feel badly yes okay good does that make
sense no absolutely i don't know if i've
ever said i feel badly or i felt badly
or maybe maybe in past tenses is it kind
of like
more better
like more better i mean
i mean that's really bad that's always
bad
badly as like i so badly wanted to go
yeah
what do you think like or she performed
well poorly would say poorly yeah
i'd say badly if i'm not thinking maybe
that's why people get it mixed up
because poorly is
acceptable um well
you know who's what's not poor
is that the person that loves to sit at
home any door dash oh my goodness yes
here do it i wanna get doordash so badly
i think that's used correctly
i'm triggered by the badly part doordash
we all know what doordash is it's an app
that connects you to your favorite
restaurants you can also get snacks
drinks other household items grocery
essentials delivered to you in under an
hour
ordering is easy open the doordash app
why are you on my phone right now
what are you doing leave my phone alone
i was trying to call steve to give me
another long island
i'll tell you
doordash steve we need another long
island with over 3 000 partners in the
u.s puerto rico canada and australia you
can support your neighborhood go to's or
choose from your national favorite
restaurants like popeyes chipotle or the
cheesecake factory
sorry there's a cat oh that's what's
happening yeah i was like
she's trying to make your long island
with like that's not where the machine
is
truly see i can't smell it
truly would appreciate you okay uh
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of fifteen dollars or more
when you download the doordash app and
enter code mood
okay
it's okay
like that oh sorry that's 25 off up to a
10 value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store in an
enter code mood don't forget that's code
mood for 25 off your first order with
doordash subject to change terms apply
and i know that you're ordering healthy
food with doordash but just in case you
wanted to stay on that healthy habit
weight loss train
noom is an incredible app that you can
use i've done so many stupid restrictive
health plans before and i always end up
bummed because like it's so hard like
keto aikido and the paleo or whatever
they're so keto
you know why you know my husband steve
green he pronounces words wrong on
purpose he does and then they get stuck
in my head that way
and it's so mean so you talk about your
keto diet channel all the time
so anyway but this is not that this is
not restrictive this is purely
psychological and also just getting you
in the good habit
train so that you don't even have to
think about eating healthy or you know
weight loss or any of that any
restrictive diets for me i found out
after using this app that i tend to
gravitate towards stress eating when i'm
stressed out i just start eating snacks
and i don't even realize i'm eating and
so that was a big weakness for me and so
re reprogramming your mind to think
differently really helps they have a
cognitive behavioral approach that
focuses on why instead of what to help
change your relationship with food
everybody's journey looks different noom
customizes a program for you based on
your personal goals
80 of new users finished the program and
over 60 have stuck with their goals for
at least a year so start building better
habits for healthier long-term results
sign up for your trial at noom.com big
mood again sign up for your trial at
noom.com big mood that's n o o m dot com
slash big mood yeah
yeah all right are you all ready for the
next in connecticut i'm waiting for
another drink oh lord mail should we
stop the show
excuse
you've done so many you do that a lot
sounds like a type of bug
that's how you say it in the east he
walks in and she just immediately
smashes him
pull the poor i like it when you guys
say that
that one the poor
we used to be a poor
okay here's another one general
consensus of opinion
final concept i've heard
true i feel like i've heard people say
really so a consensus is a generally
held opinion right so a general
consensus of opinion is an overachiever
from the department of redundancy
department
consensus by itself gets the point
across consensus says
yeah this is what happens when your
teachers keep making you hit those 200
words about 200 words like listen this
essay better be four pages long and you
over here adding ands ifs butts then
squares and theirs
like you're adding right all the words
that mean the same thing all together i
really believe that the way that we
wrote in school
messed us up i was adding all these
words because i'm just trying to fill in
spaces but i dropped out i was like this
[ __ ] sucks dude that's how i felt
was uh when i was in when i was taking
an english class in college i cuz
throughout school i didn't really pay
attention to english grammar like rules
and all that [ __ ] i just knew it sounded
correct and then in that class like i
learned a lot more like i actually paid
attention because i'm paying for it this
time and so in the beginning of the
semester all my essays were like a's and
b's and then the more i learned the
lower my grade got oh i'm like wait this
is [ __ ] me up like you'd rather just
not know all this you're better off
instinct is it because you were just
trying to follow the rules versus doing
what you felt was correct
in learning curves i feel that way like
when i learn a new subject i immediately
get worse at it yeah because i'm like
trying to integrate all these new things
that i've learned and it's messing up my
rhythm and yeah flow but then after
those get like melded into my mind it
then it goes back up to like a higher
point than it was is that why children
pick up on things so quickly because
that's just
this is what sounds good this is correct
or this is what i'm taking in and they
just follow it because you know nothing
like you're just absorbing everything
right and you're like this is knowledge
yeah exactly whether it's true or not
yeah like little kids learning a
language right like they don't know the
[ __ ] grammar rules of how you're
supposed to say things they just know
how to say it like me i can't tell you
the grammar rules of spanish but i can
tell you what sounds right and what
sounds wrong cause it's all copying who
you're around
and you could probably speak it so
you're going my conversation is better
than my
written i'm not gonna write you an essay
in spanish but i can have a full-blown
conversation and then you're getting
confirmation by those people around you
that yes you're doing it right yeah but
i could actually write it i think i
could write an essay in spanish it's
just that i suck at the accents on the
on the letters like i don't know which
ones need accents but if you're trying
to impress your boss and sound smart
some of these phrases avoid because you
will look at it
i mean
they're smarter than you
me and your boss isn't always smarter
than that that's fair sometimes they
just related to the owner
how about this one i literally have
never worked for anybody i just felt
like somebody out there
that's for you somebody's worked for
somebody
okay
about this one estimated at about oh
excuse me okay i've heard that estimated
at about 3 00 p.m or something yeah
estimated at about 300 000
yeah because that was serious about when
i need the arrival time that's the
knockoff gps that's why okay that's why
i've heard that before is this what just
estimated three hundred thousand dollars
it says when you estimate something you
roughly calculate you don't estimate
something exactly
so why need do you need to add this the
part at about
estimated at 300 i feel like that's what
uh
waze says to me
estimated at about yeah your arrival
time is estimated at about
15 more minutes what if i said estimated
around 300 000. is that i feel like it's
kind of similar estimate it's estimated
around it's still rounding it's around
that that price estimated around that
that's i have heard that one works a
little bit more i guess then it just
seems like you're missing a word when
you're like estimated 300 000. no
estimated
okay so like we don't need to soften
estimated even more by saying add about
or maybe around it's like it's already
an estimate it's not going to be exact
right so we don't need more filler words
to like soften the estimate
got it because yes you feel like this is
all ruining the flow first certainly
do you want to write my resignation
letters when they when they're necessary
around about time uh you will be needed
what about this one in close proximity
that's right okay yeah that's not wrong
somebody is being close right we can all
like look at these phrases and tell you
what's wrong with them but the fact is
people use these conversations well
maybe people don't understand why
they're wrong in close proximity to the
restaurant this is blake i ain't think
that sounds incredible in proximity or i
am close to the restaurant still sounds
right yeah it's sorry
a synonym of proximity is closeness and
close means close so in close proximity
has an overload of closeness what if i'm
just close to the proximity really
oh my god it sounds like a grammar even
though it has become such a commonly
used phrase
well this is an article written by cnbc
okay so technically it's not completely
wrong
it's commonly used yeah
it's a commonly used phrase but it's
incorrect but they're saying so you know
those programs like grammarly grammarly
like they're these are things that you
might get the little squiggly underline
for like hey you're you're using
redundancy blast through those i'm
take that green squiggly line [ __ ] i'm
gonna use it again yeah squiggle this
squiggly
if you don't make a better suggestion it
stays
true
okay
well in my opinion
tell me where it's from
you're not supposed to say that you're
not supposed to say in my opinion
when you're in an opinion
opinion okay listen yeah when you're in
opinion
you're just taking out my so we don't
even know who's opinion exactly so why
is this wrong well let me explain
opinion
when you're sharing a perspective or
insight readers already get the concept
it's your opinion there's no need to
throw in that all too overused phrase
unless
unless you're countering your opinion
with others if you really just need to
make it clear opt for a simpler i think
okay okay
it doesn't matter you're probably seeing
how it's a matter of preference i
express myself right yeah exactly so the
rule is brevity is best basically but
gravity is brevity
she said gravity
forever remedy is
doing it
okay i'm sorry i'm going to ask because
i do not know okay say that word one
more time brevity
what does it mean brief brief
i learned something new today there we
go
that sounds like bibbidy
yeah is what we call underwear oh
so i thought she was talking about
underwear yeah something like that is
one of those so okay here's where i'm
gonna i'm gonna have to argue this
because in my opinion well you're a
nurse
you're a nerd if you're gonna argue with
a nerd that makes you a nerd yeah okay
in this world where we're living in fake
facts and like people fake news and
stuff and like would you get your facts
and blah blah i like to say in my
opinion so then no one's like thinking
i'm saying this is a fact well you can
just say i think
but i don't want to i think that's a
synonym to my opinion it's a synonym so
i don't need to say it your way [ __ ]
robot grammarly nazi [ __ ] this wait i i
agree with the with the replacing it
with i think especially in a work in a
work environment because there's so many
people like
do you think or do you know yeah there's
people that literally look down on you
triggered oh my god nikki is really
triggered and then there's a lot of
people that actually give advice they
say when a work environment if you want
to be respected more don't ever say i
think yeah also ever one of the things
uh i mean menus i think all the time
well they're allowed to because they're
men but we as women yeah
well i'm not going to
i'm not going to soften my opinion by
going well in my opinion i mean this
doesn't have to be your opinion about it
right but you know i think yeah well i
think we should do this i think we
should do this on the case i've
changed using i think to i believed to
put emphasis on the fact that i am
personal i like that one the best out of
all i believe is that's a good middle
ground i've made that conscious decision
to stop saying i think because i hear it
so often and it feels like that does
soften what you're saying and it also
feels i think feels
persuasive like i feel like i can push
you over and or bring you into my side
when i say i believe i'm full
lee i'm owner
there's a little bit of strength yeah
there's a little bit of strength my
opinion can be also comes off a little
arrogant like in my opinion i am um
sometimes when i use that when i use
that terminology they're saying in my
opinion is because it's usually
when i'm doing videos and stuff because
a lot of people will take what i'm
saying and like like you're the bad guy
yeah they they project my intention as
being like oh you mean all men or like
you mean all this and it's like
well no i was just saying my subjective
view of this type of my experience yeah
it's a little in ours in our space it's
kind of the hate our disclaimer that's
the
it's a disclaimer
it's a non-combative disclosure yes
exactly when you're using
i'm not saying this is a fact but i'm
not trying to
uh be a know-it-all on you because
or negate whatever you believe yeah in a
work environment
yeah i don't think in my opinion
i believe and like you use words it
should be shorter like i don't if you're
at a conference call in a corporate
setting and you're like adding so much
padding before you give your the guys
are like [ __ ] what right what is it
and that uh again i believe using i
believe is better than i think because i
believe it's full like you ain't gonna
sway my opinion i believe this is what i
believe i don't care what you think this
is what i believe so what i believe is
more important than what you think so ah
so be it yeah and that's how you shut
[ __ ] down sometimes i mean yeah
there's this tone there's a space for
not wanting to offend and not wanting to
shut down and like really setting
yourself up for for a gentle
conversation exactly there's a lot of
times where it's just like in places
listen to me if i just said do you make
two cents do you think we should spend
advertising money on this or on that you
could just say i think we should spend
it on this right like you don't have to
oh right it depends on the content it
doesn't depend on you okay if you're
asking me to give you feedback on
something so it's all context
what do you think of this report well in
my opinion you shouldn't have included
this totally that sounds great because
it's almost leaving it a little bit like
it's preference it's saying this is my
preference rather than you should do
this and if i
said i believe this is how it should be
done it's more forceful i don't want to
necessarily hear what you have to say
back but settings
right
there's a time and a place for all these
phrases this one in particular can be
used in so many different spaces and
especially while you're talking to a lot
of people in my opinion saves you from
excluding people yeah alienating you
know kind of letting it this this is
just me
uh whatever you believe or whatever you
think that's up to you this is what this
is just my opinion it's almost like this
my opinion mm-hmm yes it's that gesture
it's like this yeah it's just my opinion
please don't attack yeah i guess like
probably this article is not in that
space where they're gonna behave in that
manner where they have to like put the
shield up yeah you know like maybe it's
a very strong man space and you know but
i mean for me i feel like i'm as direct
as this so i agree with it but i totally
100 understand what you guys are saying
yeah it depends on totally like the
situation that was handed to you yeah
right
read the room ladies and gentlemen if
you know how to do
that biggest just if you can adjust your
vocabulary or your cadence your tone to
who you're talking to it will get you
way further absolutely
it's all about how many people you can
communicate with some people think that
if they use big words or they do all
this stuff that that they sound more
intelligent but if you're talking to the
wrong crowd right you just sound like a
douchebag so it's not communicating
through points yeah exactly and they're
not getting your points so are you
really smarter for reaching less people
yeah i do think it's beautiful to have a
vast vocabulary and understand how to oh
absolutely afraid to have the option
but there is
so much more you can do with
understanding who you're talking to yeah
pull out the big guns when you need to
but also if you don't got the big guns
if you don't got the big guns don't
pretend you have them yeah because
you're going to be over here
at a rocket launcher you're going to
have somebody talking over here or some
big ass sweaters you got a nerf dart
and it's like well maybe because they
don't think you're that smart and they
don't want the client to read these
emails and stuff like interact with you
and you sound silly and you're not
competent
exactly and sometimes you don't
necessarily have to have the biggest
vocabulary you use the proper words but
if you know how to put things in their
places and deliver it man
there's something beautiful about a car
salesman yeah there's a reason why they
can go ahead and do what they do every
day is because they put a little you
know they put a tent on the two it's
what i would say they can take something
and turn it in to you know nothing and
turn it into something so there are some
people that just know how to work it
yeah and if you can pick and choose when
to be yourself and when to kind of pull
out the bigger words or dumb it down
yeah sometimes it's nicer to say i
actually don't know or on earth but this
is how i would approach the situation
and you maybe become a little bit more
real a lot of these strike me as like
i'm 20 and this is my first job and i'm
like trying my hardest to sound
professional but it just takes me
seriously yeah it's like it's a great
way to play don't you know it's like you
can tell when it's like someone's first
professional email year you know they're
like this is yeah i got my laptop out
and this is my first real job and i'm
like excuse me
roll up my sleeves and pull up the
yeah
yeah so here's another phrase postpone
until later
notice that meeting can we postpone that
meeting until later
notice i don't know i'm just adding
extra words that's even more words right
until later notice postpone until 3 a.m
in the morning
still sounds good to me
man i got [ __ ] to do we gonna party i'm
gonna write you after let me sober up a
little bit for send this email well if
you say like can we postpone this for
tomorrow
actually i think that that's fine
because you're saying specifically yeah
yeah just postpone until later
later yeah yeah post morning is later
postponed the meeting you're not giving
more information yeah okay so if you're
wanting to move the meeting yeah how
would you can we postpone this
that's it yeah can we postpone the
meeting or until you can list a specific
date and time yeah
until wednesday yeah can we give some
tips back
so can we postpone this
specifically yeah i think what happens
is people think that certain words are
kind of like more actionary and then
they they need further elaboration so
like yeah but you're never gonna do
anything with postpone other than it be
later so it's like can we postpone this
yesterday
i know i messed up okay i said can we
postpone this till yesterday at 3 a.m
good morning
it was so much better then
it made sense
you told me to sit there
it was general consensus in their
opinions
it was a collective group of opinions
okay i found one that i've used before
okay
the reason being
oh yeah the reason why that's wrong so
these guys definitely use this
is like a phrase for sure yeah
it says these sound long-winded and
pretentious the office was empty at noon
the reason being that everyone was at
lunch literally just because because
yeah yeah first off i'm trying to sound
like an ass i know if you're trying to
sound like an [ __ ] i'm trying to
sound like a reason i fired you the
reason being i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about please look back to
our prior interactions
the general consensus is that you're a
dumb [ __ ]
please don't respond to this until later
notices yeah these are the emails i get
from me
i mean
anyone's writing herself
sucks yeah i'm asleep pee pee poo poo
and then i get it i'm like come on
yeah pluralize everything your filipino
side comes out it's true but it's three
am in the morning it's five in the
morning it's by in the mornings i made
rice
wait till then you should just say the
reason was just no no or if you wanted
to say the reason like no what if
someone says like this is the reason
this is okay those words are words that
can be used but this is just using those
words at the wrong time syntax
when i say if i'm just making a
statement and i said the office was
empty at noon the reason being was that
it's like i don't we don't need to
yeah but i want to know when to use the
reason being oh when you want to care
you really need to or when to use the
reason was uh you want to be long ass
winded first off if you want to get the
juices flowing say the reason being
because hr just went and tapped into
that email because they're ready because
some [ __ ] shit's about and if hr
tapped into that meeting would you be
sweating well and the reason we and the
reason the reason being was because you
weren't using native deodorant yeah yeah
oh i got the vanilla coconut not gonna
lie
i like the melon cucumber one too
there's so many i think there's so many
scents yeah they have a lot of really
good ones yeah so nice that mandarin one
i can't remember the exact flavor but it
was so good yeah scents
you can because they use
all natural ingredients native uses
ingredients you know thank you ladies
native deodorant is made with
ingredients you've heard of like coconut
oil and shea butter it's formulated
without aluminum parabens or talc it's
also vegan and never tested on animals
it works switching to native from an
antiperspirant doesn't mean you'll have
to worry about that midday bo
oh lord with over 10 cents including
their classics and rotating seasonals
you're guaranteed to find the one you
love oh you're talking about the citrus
and herbal must yes that one's red
yeah there's a mint and eucalyptus one
but yeah
really nice our cucumber the cucumber in
mint i think it's cucumber cucumber
cucumber eucalyptus one yeah there's
combination there's a bunch there's so
many yeah coconut and vanilla is
apparently the most popular one that
one's good too i have that um maybe
you're into a more natural scent if so
native has a popular unscented option
and if you're more sensitive you can
check out their sensitive skin
collection made without baking soda
there's no risk to try free shipping on
every order in the us and native offers
a 30 day free return in exchange in the
us make the switch to native today by
going to nativedo.com
big mood girls or use promo code big
mood girls at checkout and get 20 off
your first order that's native deo.com
big mood girls or use promo code big
mood girls at checkout for twenty
percent off your first order go back to
this and let's see any words give me
words how about this one another mod
it's a modern trend and one that many
people hate adding the word situation to
describe an event
like my situation
be prepared for a strong wind situation
or we know it's wrong but it just sounds
like people don't like it's like kind of
like bros peak i don't know dude they're
like creating this they just don't get
it it's so they're not professional side
note if you ever describe something a
situation yeah that's completely that's
jersey shore started that yeah
that was a good situation in day-to-day
convo appropriate in business no what am
i supposed to say so yeah these two guys
in this situation yeah and she was going
down exactly
at this point because my description let
them know
i didn't
initiated and interrogated yes it is
situated
in situationship
you know what i'm so mad that it took
everybody so long to get
how many more do you got she's
escalated oh did you say that
perpetuated perpetuated that's good oh
that's a nice one thank you spell it
p-e-r oh my god i did not stop he was
already hitting him
i got second place in this one i was
hoping that she was gonna [ __ ] it up and
make me feel better about myself but you
just smarter nicki on the ground right
now
and situated okay wait so situation you
just when do you use it then i'm like in
conversation this is this is like a
not in a work email but in
conversation no this is using your email
this is not a situation you would use
that word yeah well that was a property
no that was a better way to say it that
was a proper use i just nikki showed us
the proper way to save the situation
i've loved it it's like it's like a cool
way to use the word situation but it's
not
what an actual situation is okay i can't
even you're just you just talk into
circles like trying to explain
what had happened
the situation called for a certain
situation
i just escalated it
like the car you instigated it no
actually
like the car oh yeah
y'all don't drop the pig you know what
that's another conversation that's that
no chaser [ __ ]
what rick would have known what i was
talking about with the escalator suvs
yeah what about it
she said she escalated like the car oh
like the car like the s it was a bar
okay
we missed the bars
oh you want to
immediately they rejected you then you
have your second choice yeah casper i
don't think so casper
that was literally not for you
the fact that your light ass when it
came at her light ass that was like you
better stop playing
you're not that far off nikki
words like past history past memories or
past records how we talk about our
x-rays
anything all of these words redundant
all of these words without past already
referred to the past you don't need to
specify that the history is a past
history
people sound like a joy to be around
past history what was the other ones
past history past memories past records
this person just put together a list of
all the times they've been triggered on
the internet
they said unless you're writing a
science fiction novel and need to refer
to the future and past history via time
travel
we don't need the past history memories
yeah that makes sense okay past memories
i think past memories might come up more
yeah but it's like keeping work in mind
helps with these yeah yeah exactly
because you're forgetting the first
thing i thought about that was the cnbc
business article well that's why i was
like
x's
you know the first thing that came was
talking about your ex's past history
yeah no yeah
experience because i feel like speaking
is more metaphorical whereas like a
business email
yeah brevity which is so
but even
even in any term though past history
doesn't is like yeah but like when
you're talking about your past history
we're talking about your past history
medical history
but they say that and when you go like
when you go to the doctor he goes your
past history or whatever what are they
doing
is
it dumbs it down that's it seems as
though that's what i'm talking about
a little bit my your past history it
just softens it i've it's more palatable
in work emails yeah
what's your medical history that would
be better right yeah or what's your work
history that would be better
we don't need past history i just feel
like certain phrases have been
integrated into modern times so it's
like just letting you know that they're
going to eat them
which is good to know
when it's necessary it now is like a
freight a turn of phrase it's not like a
it's not like it's grammar it's gone
beyond grammar yeah now like just the
way people speak like we don't say you
know four score in seven years ago let
me tell you but like well let me tell
you be proper it's all fun and games
until somebody googles you
your
phrase and it's incorrect and they show
you why it's wrong and you're sitting
there looking stupid
yeah yeah okay
okay that's a
piece of literature
it's a craft yeah
a craft it's a it's an animal that eats
trees it's a giraffe it's related to the
giraffe
yes that was the animal
you're still so mad at it we love you i
did it you're so pretty
don't do that to me
in the same category don't play me huh
it is
i'm not gonna feed into this negative
energy tip you want to hug oh man
i don't want a hug i want to fight
come on
give me a fight
oh you can just go wrap eminem in the
corner by yourself
she was attacking me i wasn't listening
actually she didn't care yeah
her right ear don't yeah
i was looking for more words and i found
out that the person i think who wrote
this also wrote this book and it's it
looks really interesting and i was like
come on why did you go buy this book i'm
not buying that you want
you guys
i'd like to remove that from any
description of myself police you're the
grandmother
you're the grammar aryan okay
i'm sorry i wasn't a dragon what is it
you're the camera authoritarian
it sounds interesting it's called that
doesn't mean what you think it means
first off who's he talking to yeah
because it does mean what you think it
means it does mean what we think it
means because we're literally saying
what it means as we're saying the other
way it's the 150 most commonly misused
words and their tangled histories i was
like oh i like that i wanted to learn
about those
history that's so freaky i like music
i want to buy this book real situation
so it sounds like the most unique book
i don't like see now i was waiting for
the rest of the words
what's going on this is how you know we
most unique
you're so fun oh my god
i'm saying i want to go to a party with
this that's one of the things this is a
party
that's that's redundant right oh it's
from oh see you know what i was i'm like
i'm like right yeah because
because unique means unlike anything
else
we don't need a sliding scale of unique
because unique
is at the very end
of the sliding scale
so you know what i'm saying this is so
fun
i
yes uh i've already decided i'm going to
be paying her i get why
now
i pissed my i would piss me off now
hey no
these are not things that you would tell
people to their face these are just
things they're saying you think in the
back of your mind and then you write a
cnbc article
you should make an account to where you
can put out proper emails for people
well that's what grammarly is for yeah
they already have a.i
[ __ ] them people you trying to get paid
[ __ ] people
it's messed up okay it's already i just
ultimately don't think that the people
judging this are more intelligent i
think they're just [ __ ]
i think it's very possible i don't i
don't think necessarily grammar equates
to intelligence to stick their flag into
and be like um
i will say this
when you are dealing with corporate
settings these are good things to know
because somebody above you is looking
down at you they're constantly
judgmental sometimes helpful it's better
to know what is happening you don't deal
with it yeah i'm not that personality
you know i'm like i can't do that's why
i can't work for anybody but you know
where we're in this space a lot of
people work in this space you're an
artist you're an artist to deal with it
right but it's it's great to know that
some of the phrases that we have used in
these spaces thinking we knew what we
were talking about somebody was looking
down at us like
that's wrong yeah so to me it's like we
are in a hierarchy and you're displaying
that you are an alert
and i will show you why i am in a higher
managerial position to you and it just
is like suck a dick
i would love to tell somebody
but the way my health insurance and my
401k
i need a property
like phrase this email before i tell
them to suck with my dick listen to me
people that don't want to follow people
who are not sheeple you can have a 401
kill me you could have
a health insurance plan
the cult of limo began this yeah you
actually have an hsa you could have it
all and you could be your own boss and
you don't have to right now
you know what when you send that
misspelled email this one's gonna know
that it's misspelling the words were
wrong actually spell misspelled [ __ ] i
can't spell
spell misspell is one of the most
frequently misspelled words i speak for
livings
you heard that living she does multiple
things i don't spell i just speaks and
speaks she speaks it but misspelled is
one of the most frequently misspelled
words i thought that was funny when i
was a grammar aryan
when you were bullied in thursday yeah
sorry i'm sorry that happens to you
isn't that why you're so triggered right
now she's so hungry she's so aggressive
she's so upset
i mean we struck a chord i didn't
realize i thought this was going to be
about me not knowing she but damn
it's like manifest [ __ ] fury oh man
can i just say this is what i feel like
nikki is giving me right now
you know what i did back in my day
i let the people tell me what to do
with my life
but now
i'll listen to nobody
but you know what i got assistant
and a 408 cake
that i recorded
4k
so if you want to be like me
straws over here out of plasticqueen's
metal
that was a mic drop right there
there's really nothing else to say go
follow nicki blaze
she is still there the wisdom the woman
thank you guys honestly
thank you so much for having me
this is our last week
yeah check out our other episodes if you
missed them with her gina's getting new
boobs that's why she's not here we got
boobs in the house anyway yeah and uh go
follow her on all of her socials and no
chaser podcasts and the morning show the
morning show
big bay morning san francisco streaming
on the podcast
it's absolutely necessary
bye